like pick a man bring your kit  I hoped today might be a good day hope  is a dangerous thing you have a brother  in the second Battalion yes sir they're  walking into a trap  your orders are to deliver a message  calling off tomorrow morning's attack  if you fail it will be a massacre let's  talk about this room minutes why  we've got all just across here that is  the German front line if we're not  clever about this no one will get to  your brother  Oh will  [Music]  there's only one way this ends  Last Man Standing  [Music]  we need to keep moving come on  we could possibly make it that way man  you bloody insane  [Music]  [Music]  if you don't get there in time  we will lose 1,600 men no brother among  them good luck  you  you